let's pull up this story here this is
big news CNBC reports yay's deal to buy
conservative social media at parlor is
called off conservative social media
company Paul said Thursday it's dealt
it's deal to be bought by yay has been
called off the rapper formerly known as
Kanye West agreed to buy the app in
October for an undisclosed amount yeah
has made repeated public anti-semitic
comments in recent months and several
business Partnerships involving the
musician have been terminated I don't
know exactly
um why they say quote the company has
mutually agreed with you to terminate
the intent of sale of parlor the app's
parent company said in a statement this
decision was made in the interest of
both parties in mid-november parlor will
continue to pursue future opportunities
for growth in the evolution of the
platform for our Vibrant Community he
brought this up in the pre-show he was
saying he said something negative about
it like I forgot what it was he was
asking me we're trying to unload it off
of me like are they trying to he's
talking to I think it was news me knows
me okay and uh Tim he was asking no no
even before that he was talking to Nick
before you even came in when you were
talking about federating parlor because
you came up you're right that's the
Federation fractals uh to break the code
and all the stuff that you always say
but before that he was like do you think
they're trying to just unload offload
this on me and put it on me I didn't
have enough details I didn't know how to
answer them and um I don't know if they
were trying to sell him 100 of the
company or if they just wanted to buy in
30 as a figurehead I don't know the
details what what I think happened here
is Adidas took or his money disappeared
so he doesn't have the money to buy
parlor now and that's probably why he
ended the deal I think he said he still
had 400 million dollars but because he
has a third of his value he's like ah
now this is going to become 700 percent
of my uh expected investment but Adidas
is is demanding 250 million dollars and
and put a hold on his account and the
IRS is demanding 50 million dollars so
he's not in a place to spend 400 million
bucks on a social network plus the
divorce with us lawyers plus fees that's
my guess my guess is that he just ran
out of funds breach of contract rules
that probably a lot of the other
companies that he's working with also
have didn't he also say that Adidas was
gonna buy the name off of him yeah they
were going to start making basically
making the easy shoes no they said they
were going to buy the name so they could
keep using it oh okay yeah I wonder if
they also announced that they're gonna
release the same shoes just yeah with
his name on it that's what I'm saying
I'm pretty sure he said in the pre-show
that they're trying to buy the name from
him like basically give him a lump sum
cut him out interesting okay well if
you're listening yay you probably did
the right thing by not buying it like
Elon lives and breathes Twitter right
now he sleeps in the office and if
you're a CEO of a tech company you got
to meet Bill ottman at mines 10 12 hours
a day that guy for the last 15 12 years
that is his life is mines and you need
to be like that if you want to be a
successful CEO of a tech company well
and this is what I think about like the
future of digital media and that's why I
look what Tim is doing is so important
because like all these cable channels
are dying they die like really quick but
I believe the future will be like how
they have an audio only RSS feed that
soon there'll be a video only or you
know like a video RSS feed and you'll be
able to pick a platform and you'll be
able to choose which content you want so
whether it's any sort of video or it's
Audio Only I I think that will be the
future because you know the media that
we have today where people are paying
for you know their cable like it is I
think that's going to die really soon
we're working on technology with the
foundation that I'm starting where
you'll have your own software packet
that you can upload video to ideally
will rumble or or your own server or
something um the when we launch it it's
going to be pretty Alpha and uh then the
idea is you'll be able to it'll to see
your mind stuff your Twitter your Rumble
maybe your parlor maybe not I don't know
if they're going to open source their
code Tim what are you smiling about I'm
looking at those chips just thinking
about oh he's ready to do it because we
spent an hour talking about Kanye we
gotta go insane for the Ukraine already
wait okay we can do it so I wasn't no
what's the timer no we're gonna do it we
can wait let's wait a little bit yeah I
got three we're gonna go I'll eat a
three
years
last time you guys were having a good
conversation and I'm just chilling I
don't want to interrupt because I was
gonna have this smile on his face now
we're talking about the future of you
know social media but so you guys were
talking about the future of digital me I
think it's very important and while you
were talking I looked over and saw that
we have three of those crazy blue fire
chips and I was just thinking about the
last time Alex ate one and it was
hilarious and so Alex is like what are
you laughing about and I I don't want to
I want to derail the concert picture
I'm Not Afraid see I'm a pimp on a blimp
so I'm not a bad chemical no no no no
blue one that's right here man stay away
the worst occasion oh I love that one
sunflower oil is bad flower oil bad
that's all that good one yeah
what are they saying in the chat we're
looking at it guys we're going uh blue
in the chat so you guys want me to do a
two-piece I think we should put these in
a case on the wall
we'll just let's we got
you can see the aftermath of Alex's
first Blue Chip Fiesta on Twitter on I
think it's Alex
uh yeah I mean uh it was insane for the
Ukraine like it keeps saying but okay
yeah real quick before I eat this but
what do you guys think about all the
money that we're giving to Ukraine do
you think that will ever stop and do you
think we're going to go into World War
III because I know you're Mr Civil War
so what about World War III or you know
Mr world war three so after today
so this morning I tweeted I think yay
could be president and so I had a con so
we were putting together uh the The
Green Room episode it finished rendering
this morning we watched it started
having a conversation with my brother
about what happened
and I was like a lot of what happened
feels like 2016 Playbook with Trump
and my brother was like you really think
he could get elected president after
saying this stuff about Jewish people
and I was like I don't know but the
media reported that Trump said Mexicans
were all rapists and that he wanted to
ban he had a Muslim ban and all that
stuff and he still gets votes so I
wonder if this is a maximized press
strategy and so then when I was thinking
about it I'm like I'm not going to
underestimate this guy I mean this this
dude is summons a private jet the snap
of a fingers kind of guy and uh I said
that
and then he went on Alex Jones's show
and then I said okay well boy was I
wrong about that because because he went
off
however some I I tweeted I'm gonna I'm
gonna keep this tweet up eat this one
because boy was I wrong about that there
are a lot of people that are like you're
wrong about a lot of things I'm like yes
I acknowledge that absolutely but then
someone said
I don't know man you might have been
right the first time because this this
everything's like going crazy and
breaking down like this past week has
been nuts yeah the past month has been
just weird and crazy it seems like
everything's just getting crazy do you
think that do you think that's weird
that the Secretary of State Katie Hobbs
can certify our own election in a
contentious place where the machines
broke down
you think there's anything like you know
tin foil Hattie uh conspiratorial about
that no I mean uh I do and when let's
just say the the only election that was
more fair and accurate than the 2020
election was the 2022 election oh and I
want to say this this is another thing
and and I know this is probably an
unpopular opinion in the conservative
world but uh because I'm truly a
populist and it's not really what I want
it's what the people want but
everybody's like oh in the conservative
we gotta get we gotta get Dr Oz we need
Dr Oz and I'm like are you idiots
smoking weed or something we need
fetterman Lurch this guy's a Content
King dude that Jersey Giselle in there
they're gonna have all kinds of talk
about drama you think Marjorie Taylor
green is interesting you think AOC wait
till Lurch is up in there he can barely
wear a tie he's got a thing growing out
of his neck the size of freaking Jupiter
I mean the guy's insane so I love you
congratulations Mr Federman what about
Walker what about her Senator fetterman
are you excited about uh Walker yeah
well and this is the other thing with
Herschel this is the only thing that
bugs me is like yeah I mean you know and
the people like oh he does better in the
debate this and that you know warnock's
the worst because I hate these guys they
act like they're pastors but then
they're pro-choice like give me a break
like I get why some people are
pro-choice I'm not I'm against abortion
I think it's terrible personally but I
hate when these pastors are like oh I'm
I love Jesus I love Jesus but I think
you know you should be able to you know
have abortion I just think that goes
against God so that's the worst but I
just don't like that freaking my man
Herschel Walker just can't be like yeah
I had an abortion I did some stuff come
on I mean I changed my mind because this
is what life is life is about the
freaking caterpillar becoming the
butterfly we're all supposed to change
we're not supposed to be the same and
there's something that's actually
likable about that somebody that can go
from bad to good so I don't know I just
don't like when they lie and guys let me
tell you something this is another thing
idolizing a politician is like thinking
the stripper actually likes you yep you
got no chance Herschel Walkers Are Gonna
Save Your Butt Dr Isaac oh save you
Katie hi
she said certainly I mean Kerry Lake's
great so you say she's going to be
Trump's VP give me a break should be my
Queen Marjorie Taylor green but I'm just
saying it's all fake and lame and I hate
to say it transsexual at this point
because nothing matters like you know
both sides it's rigged against us and I
really have really no faith in the
system so I think it's just about being
civilly disobedient and having a good
life the a life that uh once it gets as
big as Kanye they can take away from you
in an instant so treat your life like
that and just enjoy it I I agree with a
lot of that the Civil Disobedience stuff
this is why I said it feels like things
are getting crazier and crazier uh it's
it's just like the news cycle is more
and more absurd every single day yep I
think they were in the Apocalypse in the
second coming of Christ is upon us
statement but the news the news cycle
too has been a little slow in the fact
that I mean I'm not saying that as a
disrespect to you the fact that you're
leading it but it's like people are
we're like starving for news like you
know because they don't want to talk
about the elephant in the room like you
know the Epstein and excuse me not
Epstein talk about 100 Biden laptop like
there's other stuff they want to talk
about but they you know they want to
talk about Kanye all day long because
it's basically like he's like Trump
there's a revolution there's a
revolution happening in China right now
exactly
Factory I mean there's so many important
things that we could be talking about
health obesity levels are increasing to
such dangerous level sperm levels are
going down to where people in a few
decades will need to have assisted
helped when it comes to reproducing like
we're at a crisis of civilization and
and yay is the main thing of of
discussion come on man the whole chat
exploded with Ian 20 based off what he
just said hell yes that's because it's
real dude we are in an inflection point
with the internet video where our minds
are melding and it's time for the Christ
energy to come out of us each of us
individually it requires each of us to
speak our mind together we can do it
well I don't know what that means
congratulations for being here with me
well it is it's people are also asking
if you dropped acid today no no no but
but Ian has a point because I think I
talked about this last time but we are
you know energetic beings so we're
vibrational so we can either be high
vibrational or low vibrational and like
that's why they say misery you know
loves company we are like we're like
energetic like magnets so you're right
like that that's our christ-like energy
with within us and so we kind of tend to
you know uh gravitate towards people
that have that similar energy they call
it sympathetic vibration and science
where one object will vibrate and then
another one of a similar structure
across the room will start to vibrate so
the human bone for instance is a crystal
yeah Crystal people are saying Ian 20
and even Ian 100 after that last one I'm
telling you man this is what's happening
it's this is either either it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy that humans
want is someone to step up and become
the second coming or I think all of us
together are creating the second coming
of the Christ energy you never never put
your faith in one individual preach Ian
and I love what we have in the chat
because I'm always in the chat every
single episode I try to read every
single chat and whenever someone makes a
point there's some Grace in the chat my
man Brothers everyone ends in chat
always writes at everyone's performance
from one to twenty and you can see one
or Twenty yeah yeah but sometimes it's
15 sometimes it's five it depends yeah
and it's it's usually you're right it
usually is one or Twenty but I think
that's awesome in the chat room and it's
good seeing that feedback automatically
I picture so keep ranting I pictured an
alternate uh reality where I ran after
Kanye when they left and then had a
conversation with him and he was like
let's go back in and we come back in and
the Articles were like that would have
read Kanye West Storms off of Tim pool
interview comes back with Jesus and it
just shows Kanye with a frown like same
frown on his face but I'm there next to
him because people tell me I look like
Jesus well the whole episode you're
hoping that Kanye comes back you're like
is he gonna come back is he gonna he was
hanging up that would have been that
would have been the episode that changed
the world if he came back and I was
sitting there and people were like that
guy looks like Jesus Christ is here like
I'm not saying I'm not I'm I want to be
like Jesus he inspired me that that idea
that someone could be like that in
reality that I I it's I like long hair
you know whatever I don't really care
about the look it's just that's what I
want well and to say that like I think
that's why it's important though that
you do Platform people like Nick Fuentes
Tim because like people like you said
why it was important for them to go on
Alex Jones to hear their thoughts so
it's like you know that's why it just
sucks because the people wanted him to
come on so bad I wanted to hear both of
them when they left I'm just like
sitting there like oh so anti-climactic
it's it's it's kind of a crazy thing too
because I know there's a lot of things
that people don't like what he said
they've made fun of a lot of things that
he said but he says a lot of things that
a lot of people would agree with when
he's uh he was talking about nationalism
he was talking about working class stuff
like you don't get to hear that you only
get to hear the worst possible thing and
that's probably one of the reasons why
they don't want someone like him to have
a platform of course I think he believes
things that are that are wrong
completely disagree with but then he'll
also say something where you're like oh
okay then then it's humanizing if
someone like Fuentes can come on and say
he's not racist that he actually he
thinks p people are different but
everybody can get along you can call
them you can call him a liar and all
that stuff but have the conversation
it's the perfect allegory of Christ he
was defending the weakest of the
prostitute it was like if any of you are
a sinless then criticize who here has
not done something wrong they would get
them canceled every one of us has done
that um
that Ian once explained how to make
chloramine gas
yeah he's uh he's vibing he's vibrating
literally yeah man this has been on my
monologue but but I just have to admit
and you know for you know for me once
again being a stand Nick Fuentes is
hilarious and he's funny and I do think
he is a little misunderstood because I
really don't think you know now Kanye
where he's going I just I think he's
watched a lot of those you know Black
Hebrew Israelite type documentaries yeah
Farrakhan so he's kind of like in that
like oh you know there's an evil cabal
of people you know the Jewish Illuminati
you know I think Nick's uh maybe was in
that at one point and just kind of
realized it's a little nuanced because
let me just tell you something I'm a
full-blown conspiracy theorist there is
an evil group of people but it's from
all different groups of religion and
Society it's not one and you know it's a
secret group we're not in it but it's
not just one group that no because I
know so many great Jewish of every you
know denomination so it's just it's not
that's not but you didn't say the
Illuminati he didn't say anything I know
okay did you guys see the Jimmy Kimmel
video about Fuentes I think it was Jimmy
Kimmel right
for what do you mean Kimmel played a
clip of Fuentes talking about how there
are gay men who have slept with women so
that must mean being who said that
Fuentes
Jimmy Kimmel that yeah but I'm like that
was hilarious did they not realize he
was joking like it was a bit like he was
being funny and they were like haha look
at how dumb he is and it's like you guys
you missed a joke he's being sarcastic
it was it was it was a bit and it was
funny and this this happens all the time
on Twitter and it's become like a meme
where like
the left doesn't understand when someone
is being sarcastic or making a joke they
think everything's literal yeah it's
just it's kind of weird to be honest I I
once was was saying that one of the
divides in the culture war is the right
is willing to believe certain things may
be jokes and that could be dangerous
when they're not but they're willing to
look for the humor and and try and give
someone the benefit out and the left
thinks everything is literal all the
time yeah yeah obviously not literally
all the time they think things are
literal like many of them will take
everything literally even when I like I
tweeted something like uh the the
intelligence agencies that crafted me
into a personality had it right prop
someone up to take all the heat off to
have a conversation with my Handler and
I had people being like so you admit it
and like um you think they're joking but
there's like long-winded responses there
people like we see you and we know who
you're working with and stuff like that
and I'm like these people think that was
real like they think I'm being serious
when whatever man there's only so much I
can do you know well and sarcasm is lost
on both sides to be honest but more so
on the left for sure in text that's a
big problem with modern cultures people
are trying to use text to tell sarcastic
jokes and the con the con it's not there
there's no contact yeah a lot of people
take themselves too seriously as well
seriously yeah I've got a I got uh
someone said that this it's the show is
staged I got here a script that uh oh
yeah there we go another copy of that
yeah this was uh uh delivered by Jack
besobic himself we filmed it uh he's on
camera delivering this in a little wagon
and then we read the lines thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time